Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr what's
going on.
Huh?
Um,
it's uh,
what the fuck is it?
It's um,
it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Sarah
[inaudible]
just checking in on you.
Just checking in on you.
Just seeing how your week's going.
Huh?
Is it going the way you planned it?
Did you have any plans?
Think about that.
That's like some self helps you think about that.
People like when you start
your Workweek d do you have a plan?
I mean other than getting in your car,
kissing your wife or,
or,
or husband or,
or a partner or,
or,
or are,
are,
and you drive down the street and an n n and you get yourself a coffee and you
going to work.
But,
but do you have a plan beyond just taking the vessel that holds your Saul
into that workplace?
Do you have a plan?
Because I'll tell you right now,
God has planned,
God has a plan for you and you and you and each and every one of you,
but you have to listen.
How can we know what our plan is,
what his plan is for us
if we don't listen?
That right there is why I don't go to church.
The the,
the,
the use of,
of vocal dynamics,
they always get way up.
Yeah.
Dang.
I got both.
I got willow
and they come in for the whisper.
Right?
That's how it works.
It's called the Sandusky.
I'm sorry,
everyone from Penn state.
I know your teams ranked.
I know you're thinking you're gonna fucking somehow slip and slide your way out
of the horrors of that shower and that no asshole sports fan like me is going to
bring it up.
Oh No.
It's going to be brought up.
Jesus Christ.
I'm going to take all this shit I took for some fucking air pressure.
You know,
I think you're going to take down one goddamn statute.
We all know you're going to put it back up one of these days.
We all know Joey.
Pause coming back up.
Where you going to put it?
Huh?
Were you going to put it probably in the boosters room,
right when they bring all the money in,
they're all sitting there going,
it's okay Joe,
you didn't know what we all know.
You never took a shower in fucking 60 years.
Why am I,
why am I doing this?
I,
you know what?
I don't know why.
Cause I got a bunch of shit to do today and that's the first thing that came to
my head.
You know why?
Because God,
God has a plan for me.
He has a plan for me to go on this podcast each and every Thursday and just
checking on your week.
That's my mission.
You what?
I finished Westworld and I have to rewatch the final episode again because I
didn't get it all right.
Granted I was fucking nod enough,
like a big headed drunk jackass on a cross country flight,
you know,
head waken me up.
You know,
I didn't quite get it.
Um,
but I know there's going to be a season two,
so I would think that would be,
I gotta I gotta figure out what the fuck happened.
Uh,
I'll watch it again.
But it was really hard to watch it because my wife wasn't in,
she wasn't into this series,
so she would,
every time I would watch an episode,
she would come in when the song was coming on and she would just sing along.
She would sing like a
robots fucking people.
People dress like cow boys something blah,
blah,
Blah blue.
What does it mean?
Like,
I don't know,
there's a certain,
you know,
there's certain kinds of white shit that Nia just can't watch.
And I found that it's like pre,
I don't know what it is.
It's,
there's a a I think anything pre happy days,
you know,
she's just like,
yeah,
this was not,
you know,
it's like the Louis CK bit like,
these weren't the good old days for us.
So I think when she sees white dudes walking around in cowboy hats,
yeah,
she just does not get a good warm,
fuzzy feeling.
Sorry.
If you could have been tuning in late to the podcast you haven't told tuned in
lately?
Um,
I,
I have a touch of a bowler,
but fortunately it's just quarantined into my trope.
You know what it is,
is I got this cough and then I smoked a couple of cigars and then I came back
and do a house with,
you know,
whenever they say the job is finished,
it's not finished.
They have their punch list and that's a,
all this shit they need to do and then the jobs fucking done so they keep
kicking up dust here and um,
anyways,
so all Billy red velvet cake is,
um,
the last few weeks was not working out because he
had this little bit of a cough and I am exaggerating the cough before you guys
are like j just shaking my head,
fuck my life.
Lol.
You only live once,
um,
all over my Twitter account.
I uh,
yeah,
I haven't been working out or anything,
so I just got on the little fucking scale and I,
in the five I lost.
I type,
I just put it right back on.
You know what I mean?
I'm really disappointed in myself.
So,
uh,
I did the half hour cardio this morning.
Do it with me.
Here you go everybody.
I'm doing a half hour cardio every day,
every fucking day of getting on that fucking elliptical.
And I'm going to try to lose two pounds a week.
Drop eight pounds,
get my fucking fed freckled ass down to about a buck 75 sliding into the fucking
new.
Yeah.
You don't like is God.
God wants you to be skinny.
He doesn't want you.
One of the seven deadly sins is that spaghettio fatty motherfucker laying face
down in his bull shit
from that movie seven.
Um,
so anyways,
so I've gotten back in,
I got my,
I got the sports channels now.
So I've been watching my bro ends.
Is there a,
you know,
get through this fucking season here,
trying to figure out what's gonna work,
what doesn't?
Um,
we lost to the filthy flyers.
You know what sucks?
It was,
I watched the first two periods.
It was too.
Nothing flyers and a very subdued,
quiet fucking crowd too would made me feel bad.
You know what I mean?
Usually the Bruins and flyers get together.
It's a rowdy fucking crowd I think because we're both fucking transition.
I don't even,
I,
you know what,
I haven't looked at the standings.
Maybe the flyers are good this year.
I don't know.
So I go out to the kitchen,
you know,
the brand new kitchen that's still is the fucking punch lists to make myself
something to eat.
And I swear to God,
I felt like I was gone for five minutes.
I came back,
it was two to two,
right.
Marshawn scored,
I forget who else.
And uh,
we went into overtime and then we lost it.
Sorry.
No,
we fucking lost it.
So,
and I've been kind of keep my eye on the Celtics.
I know we got Sacramento next.
Um,
but uh,
you know what's so fucking dumb was that complete nonstory of our center,
Al Horford getting criticized for four missing.
Uh,
I think he missed the Miami Heat game because he,
the,
cause you know he was with his wife because she was giving birth to his
daughter.
Oh Jesus.
Who has the fucking nerve to call me during podcasts.
Don't you know God has a plan.
People when you walk away from your recorder,
always make sure you take off your headphones.
Cause if you know you're gonna Yank that fucker right across the Roman and then
you're gonna have all that silence that you just heard.
Unless I took the time to edit it out,
which I probably will.
I'll probably do your salad.
And I know what a lot of you millennials are probably saying.
Actually,
I don't know what you're saying.
You know,
you probably too busy having a fucking,
uh,
doing the mannequin challenge or something else.
Really important.
Um,
why talk down to the youth bill?
Why would you do that?
Huh?
Is it cause you're your everyday creeping towards death?
Um,
[inaudible] I know what you,
you fucking technological douche bags are probably thinking,
why don't you,
can
we just get some wireless headphones?
You know why?
Cause I think I got enough satellites pointed at my fucking head.
How about that?
I've got enough signals going in there.
I can't remember shit.
I've had this cough for two weeks.
You know when I'm blaming wireless headphones,
um,
you hear that echo in my office.
That's cause I cleaned the fuck her up,
Cli this fucker up and I got rid of a bunch of shit.
I organized a bunch of stuff.
I shredded a bunch of shit and I'm feeling good about it.
I know where all my stuff is.
I'm selling the Prius and you know,
it's funny,
I have the title to every God Damn fucking car I've ever,
except for one,
you know my first one,
but I,
I had an [inaudible] 88
I had an 88 fucking a Honda accord LX that I bought in like 1996,
five speed.
I fucking loved that car.
And I had it for like four or five years before I sold it.
When I moved back to New York.
And,
uh,
I found a copy of that title.
I found every fucking goddamn title that I needed except for the fucking,
the one for the car that I'm selling.
So now I had to send it away.
I got to send away for it for the,
uh,
to the fucking DMV.
So I gotta do that bullshit today and do it.
I gotta tell you something,
just laugh all you want about the Toyota Prius.
Say as much homophobic stuff as you want at people who drive Toyota.
Prius's not only is that a great God damn car,
it's got great resale value.
People want that fucking car.
You know,
Tony,
that gas smells laugh all you want.
Say it looks like a doorstop.
Say it's gates solely as she got no balls.
You know,
I don't understand people that identify themselves with their car.
I understand liking cars.
I love cars,
you know what I mean?
But I don't like look at something that another man built an act like I had
something to do with it.
Like a lot of these other cons.
Now there's one thing if you fucking,
you know,
you,
whatever,
you go down to the goddamn junkyard like the gas monkey guys and your build it
from fucking scratch,
then you can have some pride,
all right?
But if you're that fucking huckleberry that walks out of their lot and then buys
it for four to five grand more than what you should have fucking paid for,
then you walk around leaning against it as you drink in Austros beer.
Right?
Staying in there like you won a war.
I don't understand that aspect of it.
Which brings me back to the Toyota Prius.
All right.
The Toyota Prius.
Like most of you,
I did not build that car.
All right,
so
why you try to put that on to my personality?
You know,
it takes a strong man to drive a Prius.
Nia.
Yeah,
you up?
What do you mean?
How can you not be your awake earlier when I talked to you?
Yeah,
no,
pull that shit.
You already ruined my day with all the jobs you have for me.
Can you please come up here and sing your Westworld Song?
Okay.
Can you do that?
Poo Poo,
poo,
booboo.
What are you so grumpy about?
The goddamn door open.
You're screaming at the top of your lungs.
It's like,
what are you doing to me?
What do you want?
I'm making money.
Well,
how are you doing?
Quieter?
Hey,
let me hear the uh Oh,
shut up.
You've already awake.
That's your big complaint that you pick complaint in life.
What are you doing?
I need a place to six.
Well,
sit here.
I'm moving all my shit.
Come over.
You got to sing the song.
What?
Are you pregnant or something?
Just came up the stairs and I'm out of breath.
Do you want from me?
I'd like a little sunshine today.
Do you want another microphone or what?
You want to be on the podcast
in a minute?
Yeah.
Jesus.
I got to hit pause.
Let her catch your breath.
All right.
What back?
Hell,
Nia,
I want you to show called Westworld.
Please do flash me.
I'm not flashing.
Sorry.
I got my bathrobe.
You like Sharon Stone right now it's like,
oh,
there's the,
there's the Photoshop for the pocket week.
You're in your red sox row with nothing on underneath there.
Nick,
can you have a little consideration for the listeners?
They don't want to think about that.
Jesus Christ,
they worked out.
I'm a fuck a guy.
You know,
you take your shower,
you put on a robe,
you have a couple of fucking eggs.
What I'm trying to do is I'm trying to get all this shit done before you fucking
all the crap that you decided in your head that I was doing today without
checking with my schedule.
Yeah,
yeah,
I did that.
Yes,
you did.
All right.
Well,
Noah,
sing Westworld song.
Okay.
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo.
Fucking people.
People dressed as cowboys.
Boy Is that as far as I can.
God Are you?
Do you fucking ruin the whole song every time I went to go watch it?
Now let me ask you this.
You kind of,
I noticed like this certain types of fucking white movies you don't like and
cowboys is one of them.
Anytime the cowboys you fucking tune out.
I'm just not particularly interested in certain era's of white history.
That's what I'm saying.
I knew that I called that earliest certain things I'm just not particularly
interested in.
I talked them,
you don't see a lot of black cowboys in those movies.
It's weird.
Huh?
Where were the black people during that time?
They,
let's see.
Well it depends on when it was and it was like the 1880s you mean they had,
you know,
did you guys have your own stage coaches at that point?
Oh yeah.
Definitely.
Had our own states.
The air shocks on him and show him businesses.
Yep.
I thought you did initially and you started kicking the shit out of white
people.
Cause then they went whoa,
Whoa,
easy.
Didn't it happen right after slavery now there wasn't then you guys,
a bunch of you got elected and shit and then it into what?
Well cause you had numbers.
Numbers for what?
What are you talking about right now?
I can't remember if this is a video game.
If this was
no like right after you guys got free or your sense of history is just,
it's amazing.
I thought like you guys got freed and then you started
succeeding and then all the broke ass white people around you lie.
Why?
Why are you don't man?
And that's when they came up with the client.
Maybe.
Maybe too many of these terantin no movies where he fucks with history.
I don't know what's going on,
but I thought I thought you were doing it right.
None of this,
none of this is correct.
I'm not a historian,
but I didn't.
The clumps do something around them to the whole,
the clumps.
Who are the clumps?
Eddie Murphy and fucking knows.
Oh,
you're just being silly.
Yeah,
pizza.
Silly.
All right,
whatever.
So Nia,
what exactly are you that,
that that song was a little disappointing,
but I don't really have much.
What was I saying?
I was like Anthony Hopkins playing God.
Yeah,
you'd ruin the whole fee.
Every time I would go to watch it,
you'd stick your head in the room.
Jeffrey ry,
they're a kid.
Thandie Newton.
Then
HPO is a bunch of perverts.
They always have these shows.
Everybody's just fucking naked Ahs.
Westworld,
three kings.
What are the,
fuck.
Hey,
we're all in the castle.
Look out for the Dragon,
game of Thrones,
eight year old king.
Hey,
hey,
we're all,
I don't get how an eight year old guy,
the dragon.
How does an eight year old king fucking sentence someone to death.
I never watched.
Why don't you just say,
would you say you little shit?
I have no idea.
Tip you over in that giant fucking chair.
What are you gonna do about it?
A little evil fucker.
Yeah.
That kid needed the living shit kicked out of him.
Hmm.
And yeah,
I didn't watch a lot of episodes,
but if ever I could throw an eight year old off a building or a castle,
definitely I'd want him to live to zap over this theory is,
I,
I have no idea.
I saw one of them.
He pulled the guy's fucking tongue out cause he didn't like the song he was
playing.
Yeah.
There's like too much like incest and dragons and shit.
I'm just that kind of genre.
I am not really into,
although I did love game of [inaudible] um,
uh,
Lord of the rings.
That was an awesome movie.
The part of white history.
Does that take place in?
It doesn't.
It's make believe it's not real.
I like fan like some fantasy stuff,
but I don't like,
there's no middle earth,
I don't think so.
Middle Word,
head to vote.
Which way would they go near?
Hm.
That's a good question.
I don't know.
You'd have to talk to some like token nerds for that.
They might be able to tell you if they're more liberal or conservative in this
fantasy.
Speaking of nerds,
Chris Hardwick from the Nerdist,
he's doing a fucking game show that I'm calling it right now is going to be the
biggest hit game show since.
Who wants to be a millionaire?
It's called the wall.
I don't know what it is,
but it's fucking broke ass people who could possibly win 12 million bucks in the
fact that so many people are upside down in their houses and the look of fucking
hope on these people's faces.
It's just
like
literally almost breaking down crying like you never see that on the prices.
Right?
You don't see that on the wheel of fortune.
You certainly don't see it on jeopardy,
but this wall thing,
they got these fucking people like,
like these people are so excited to win the fucking prize in the trailer that
they're gonna need some sort of counseling if they lose,
if they blow it.
Right.
Did they ever do that shit anymore on game shows member back in the day when you
could fucking bully people and tease them where it's like,
do you want to take that money in my pocket now?
I'd buy dye number two.
It'd be like,
and people always just like,
fuck them.
Right?
Then they would listen to the crowd and there'd be 700 bucks,
which could buy you like a fucking,
you know,
I don't know why they probably buy a a mercury monarch back then or some shit
and nice down payment on one.
Anyways,
you'd put it back into the guys Ron Burgundy sport coat,
and then they would open up the door and half the time it'd be like a fucking
donkey or a yak or some shit and they go dump off the tome that on let's make a
deal with Wayne Brady or do they still do that?
Still have that show?
Yeah,
he's the host of it.
I've only,
yeah,
but this is the thing,
but they all dressed,
they're all dressed up though,
so that takes the shame away from it because you can hide in your costume.
Back in the day you stood there and you looked like what you look like and then
the next day you were walking down the street and you're like,
oh my God,
you're that guy that could have fucking one seven or eight it.
Wait a minute,
I didn't.
I when we were in that,
that rental home with the Campbell that only had oldies television for some
strange reason,
I saw an episode of let's make a deal,
and there was a couple that was dressed up as raggedy Ann and raggedy Ann.
No,
no,
absolutely.
It was like in the 70th that show they did,
but I'm saying they were all,
there was all these other games shows where people didn't dress up and there was
always the booby prize is what they called it and it was not titty.
Um,
all right,
when you something fucking nuts,
this is what we want to come to a complete non fucking story.
I started to talk about it and then of course they'll fucking went away and the
goddamn cable's out.
Not the cable,
the fucking Goddamn Internet.
Like press the reset button on the,
all right,
the router.
So this Guy Al Horford who plays for the Celtics,
he used to play for the land for the sallies.
He used to play for the Atlanta Hawks.
This year we were making a big,
uh,
we want to try to get Kevin Duran and then we couldn't.
So then evidently all the money that we were going to give him [inaudible] we
gave three quarters of it to this guy.
Al Horford gave him like 130 fucking million dollars over four years or
something crazy like that.
Um,
maybe a little less than that came out to about 28 million years.
So listen to this shit.
So this fucking guy,
his wife has a kid,
right?
Has a daughter.
So he misses a game and some fans bitched about it on like a social media and it
actually became like a story.
He sat out a game because he wanted to go to his daughter's birthday,
like yeah,
party.
And then a couple of Douche bags are like,
know what the fuck to
pay you?
All the money was put ball ballroom and then the media picked up on it.
And then he actually,
he actually had the comment on Twitter nerds and it was like one sports show
that brought it up.
Are His priorities true?
Hmm.
What are you going to do in here if I don't show up?
You know,
if I'm at the Rose Bowl hammered and you give birth or um,
um,
we've already discussed that.
You don't even joke about,
Huh?
Hammered.
We've already discussed the,
the,
the plan for the Rose Bowl.
Can I tell you something to you?
And having given,
even if I walked into the delivery room blind drunk,
you can't,
you're still going to be totally fine because everybody doing all the heavy
lifting is there.
I,
I shouldn't even be there.
I don't understand why you keep trying to like evade any kind of like role of
being like my support and comfort Mike.
My emotional support.
Yeah.
You don't even stay in the room when I get my teeth cleaned.
That's a little bit different I think.
Yeah.
What if they were removing a tooth?
Would you stand there and hold my fucking hand?
You know,
for God damn sure.
That is not the same thing.
Why are you even bringing that up?
Because it's,
it's fucking bullshit that the guy has to be in there.
And every guy I talked to,
nine out of 10 of them go,
yeah,
it's bullshit.
Just stay north to the fucking blanket.
It keeps him happy.
You just want us just emotionally support me.
And when we went to the class the other day and you watch the birthing story,
you leaned over to me.
You were like,
oh,
I understand now I understand why.
No,
when he was walking with her,
walking with her in the halls,
I understood that being in there for the procedure,
I completely don't understand and I just think that that is one of those things
that it's just one of those,
it's that fucking hat.
It's that thing that you guys do and rub.
Right.
Rub My back and be like,
you got this,
you're good.
Just breathe.
Like you're okay.
Yeah.
All that kind of,
it's like,
it's just like every time I walk out the fucking door and I got all this shit to
do.
You always throw a couple more things.
Hey,
go get the dry cleaning.
Can you go do this?
Can you go do that?
And yet you're dumping your fucking,
you taking the eight off of whole pile.
You take the dog to the vet.
Actually
I'm not taking the doctor that you're taking the dog to the vet.
Okay.
Yeah,
I'm moving all that other shit down there.
[inaudible]
you're going to have some help.
You're not the only,
I mean,
you know my brother is he,
cause you're on the podcast that you're coming with this,
this fucking arrogant tone I don't know is because you're on the podcast that
you're coming at me with this extra fucking Douchey vibe.
I always have this vine.
Fair enough.
I've got some ads to read.
Oh,
did you think,
um,
oh frame was it frame grab,
frame grab.
Is that,
is that the right,
is that the way to say
it?
No,
I knew who they were until you just said it.
Is these people that advertise?
Yeah.
Oh,
on our podcast they send us a couple of frame things.
Who stuff was very nice of them.
What the fuck is their name?
Frame.
Greeks.
Frame use.
I can frame a versus framer.
What is it?
Ah,
I know where I can go to figure out.
Oh well you go figure it out.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna read some advertising.
All right.
Oh Shit.
Nia,
look at,
is he advertising?
Give me the look.
I get a little bit,
I got a little cute biggie smalls on my desk,
a loot crate from thanks to Joe Rogan,
he hooked me up with that.
Uh,
loot crate everybody.
Be The envy of your friends and get a hundred percent exclusive
crates@lukecraig.com slash burr and enter my code B U R R to save $3.
Oh Holy Shit.
It's the price of a sloppy Joe off on any new subscription.
Oh,
frame bridge.
I'm sorry.
Frame Bridge where the people that hooked us up.
Thank you very much.
That's an advertising within advertising.
All right,
waiting N***a.
You gotta listen to this stuff.
Loot crate.
Okay.
Wait until I tell you about December's crate.
Nia.
You wait right in that door frame.
It will have you fighting the power.
Oh Shit.
Is this blaxploitation um,
loot crate offers an epic range of pop culture items for less than $20 a month.
If you are a more fanatical Fashionista,
Nia,
then try loot where?
Monthly wearables and accessories with cult classics and your favorite
franchises.
Let's see if they're advertising towards the African American community too with
some of this shit.
If you want to get fancy,
get a bigger box with even bigger lute with Luke Craig DX.
Does that mean you're fatter?
Oh,
that would be loot crate.
Xxl.
Right.
Want to geek out your pet.
Try loot pets up.
Jesus Christ.
They try it.
They're trying to cover too many bases here.
Offer expires December 19th at 9:00 PM.
Uh,
get ready for December's rebellious theme revolution.
Nia,
they're always watching.
All right,
here we go.
Let's see what,
let's see what they got here.
They've designed a system to keep you down and they're metal in their ma.
Meddlesome hello friends.
It's time for the,
for a revolution.
December's crate features exclusive items from assassin's creed,
anything near
Mr. Robot firefly,
all of the TV show and our monthly tee shirt and pin and more including
exclusive Funko pop.
Oh Jesus.
That sounds like a bunch of white dads in a bed.
Garageband.
We are Funko pop.
Uh,
do not wait.
You have until the 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific to subscribe for December's crate.
When it's over,
it's fucking over.
No more crates.
Go to Luke,
crate.com/burn into my code.
Bird saved $3 off on any new subscription today.
Alright,
couple more of these.
He looks Hellickson.
You know what?
Your unique,
let's start by pandering to you and your fucking ego.
You're unique.
You know,
walk like everyone else.
Talk like everyone else or even sleep like everyone else.
Uh,
so why is your mattress one size fits all part of?
They know how the fuck you sleep.
They must be watching it through your smart television,
right?
Fucking Weirdos,
because it truly customized mattress will cost you five to 10,000 bucks until
now.
Go to helocs helix,
sleep.com helocs okay.
It's never been.
It's always helix.
I want,
what do you know about it?
I know that it's not Alex.
All right?
He likes sleep.com.
Answer a few simple questions and they'll run a three d biochemical model of
your body and then sell that to another corporation for profit.
Some of them from prior shit,
proprietary algorithms they've developed with the help of the world's leading
Irregardless and biochem.
Dude,
they're fucking taken a whole thing of your body so they can turn it into a
robot.
And that's your replacement.
Westworld.
And that fucking mattress is your coffin.
But
the result,
the most comfortable mattress you've ever slept on,
people's sleeping on mattresses,
robots replacing them though.
Helux Helix fuck customers report a 30% improvement in overall sleep quality.
How do you know you was sleeping?
Um,
and from couples.
Oh Jesus.
Now we're getting funky.
He'll Funko pops to be playing in the background on this one.
They customize each side of the mattress.
Your mattress arrives at your door in about a week and shipping is 100% free.
That's why everyone from Gq magazine to Forbes are all talking about helix
sleep.
You have a hundred nights to try it out.
And if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free.
Yeah,
with a fucking hazmat suit on and give you 100% refund,
no questions asked.
Go to a Heloc,
sleep.com/burn and get $50 off your first order.
That's helix,
sleep.com/burr helix,
the cats,
sleep.com/burr oh I kinda liked the idea of them doing a scan of both of us so
you can adjust the mattress for both of our sizes.
Really?
That's a cool idea.
No,
it isn't.
Why isn't it a course?
They're going to scan your body,
right?
And then they're to,
that's that lives in their system and then somebody gonna buy that.
The scanner,
your fucking body and it'll make you a health insurance.
Go up and everyone's going to know what size of jeans,
so people are going to call you up,
you know,
he goes,
just fucking,
everybody calls her home phone.
We never answer our home phone.
By the way,
every time you pick it up at just recording,
it's drop everything you're doing and listen to this opportunity for your
business.
Do you wear a size 34 32 genes?
How do I know that?
Thanks to Helix.
Sleep.
All right,
tracker.
Speaking of big brother,
we're all loses Newsweek reports.
The average American wastes 55 minutes a day looking for things they own but
can't find.
Not when you reorganize your fucking office.
Like I don't know why.
Just pointed at you want to do that.
I know in a very sharable Nia,
you can do this one.
Share a story when you lost something you needed.
Uh,
what?
Talk about the time I broke up with you please.
Um,
tracker makes losing things a thing of the past and I'll tell you how to get one
for free and a minute tracker is a coin size device that fits to the base of
your skull.
Um,
trackers,
coin size,
device that locates misplaced keys,
wallets,
bags,
computers,
anything in second,
just pair of tracker to your smartphone,
attach it to anything and find his precise location with the tap of a button.
It's that easy.
I don't know why I don't do this.
Why don't I do this near you?
Because you have this like thing with technology that you just resist.
Even when the Q color,
keep the show going,
lose your phone,
press a button or help on tracker and your phone rings.
Even when it's on silent tracker is finding over a hundred million,
over a million misplace items each day.
Orders Order Yours and never lose anything.
Again,
listen,
I'm gonna if I put the one over my eyeballs,
why not lose my place when I read the copy up?
Jesus,
listen to this show.
Get a free tracker.
Bravo with any order,
go to the tracker.com and enter Promo Code Burr.
The hardest thing you'll ever have to do is find their website.
Go to tracker.com right now and enter the Promo code burn for your free tracker.
Bravo with any order.
Again,
hey,
that's tracker.com promocode Bert and lastly,
but not leastly.
Oh,
which Siki everybody asleep.
It's seat Geek.
Everything about seek is designed to make life easier for sports and music fans.
Siki does all the price comparisons for you by searching multiple tickets sites
and ensuring that you get the best possible deal,
does all the work and you save time and Minsky and seek wants to help you get
the most bang for your buck.
That's why every ticket on SeatGeek has given a grade based on value.
You're worth nothing.
The Milwaukee Bucks.
Um,
you'll immediately see any under pride enough.
They suck.
I don't want to under price seats to be able to find the best deals that fit
your budget.
Best of all my listeners and anybody else who reads this copy,
get a $20 rebate off their first SeatGeek purchase.
Call to action.
Must read.
I'll tell me what to do,
your cons,
uh,
to get your $20 rebate on tickets,
download the [inaudible] APP,
go to the settings tab and click on,
add a promo code.
Enter
the Promo Code Burr seek equals send you $20 after you've made your first
purchase,
download the SEATGEEK APP and enter Promo Code.
[inaudible].
All right,
there we go.
What are we up to here?
Oh,
33 minutes.
Well,
I've fulfilled my obligation.
Yeah,
I started off doing,
I did a little bit of the church this morning because I'm wearing a robe with
nothing underneath it.
I'm having this,
this Catholic church,
five in this row you're talking about.
What are you talking about?
Um,
neo.
Do you think God has a plan for you?
Cause I'm here to tell you that he does.
I feel like an underlying time,
you could have been one of those TV evangelists.
I could literally do it as a joke and just to see how far I get and then the
energy,
everybody their money back,
but then they'd be mad at me.
I'm just fucking with you.
I don't know what you're going to go to hell or not.
Here's your money back.
I just joshing yet.
Just kidding.
Remember when Jesus died and then he came back fucking with you.
That's what I was doing.
How's that cough doing?
It's doing great with me.
Yeah,
it's doing fine.
I'm going to go play drums after this by the way,
before you have me move half of this fucking house.
All right,
well,
all right.
When,
when,
when like what is my schedule today?
Can I put a tracker on my fucking,
uh,
like when did you have me moving all of this shit coming over at noon.
He's kind of,
yeah,
don't hit me with your Calabasas fucking accent.
You haven't been out here long enough for that shit.
All right.
You make me so tired.
I'm hungry.
I had to make some Turkey bacon and some eggs or something.
You make me so damn tired.
You deal.
You make me tired.
I'm already tired and you're making me even more tired.
Weight tracker.
How about that?
Uh,
the little,
the little baby low jack.
Did you talk about that?
Oh yeah.
We went to the hospital yesterday because the hospital told me they give you a
tour of the hospital.
Nia goes,
hey,
let's take a tour of a couple of hospitals to see where we want to fucking
deliver.
So I'm like,
all right,
I'm thinking of a walk around.
Yeah,
look at those nurses.
They're pretty hot.
Let's go here,
right?
We fucking show up.
We got to sit down in another class and she's like,
this is going to be 90 minutes long.
It's like,
fuck me.
Fuck me.
90 fucking minutes.
So we're sitting there and she goes,
fringe first.
Let's go around the room and introduce each other.
Say Your names and what you're having and all that.
So right there,
I'm like,
this is going to be by the end.
I loved her.
I thought she was great,
but like I am,
I,
you know,
I'm a comedian.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't do well in the group dynamic.
You how bad I wanted to say.
My name was Russel.
This lie.
Yeah.
I wanted her to lie and I just wanted to lie about what we were having.
I just wanted to lie.
I want to lie to all of,
it's none of your fucking room for just show me where she's going to fucking
have it.
I sat there for 90 minutes people,
all I have to do is fucking pull up,
drop her off,
go to the fifth floor,
make a right and I dial four numbers and I'm done.
And I had to sit there for 90 minutes.
One hour was her talking and then 30 minutes is a great speaker though.
She was,
and she was adorable and she was a great mom and I loved her and they gave all
the dads diaper bags at the end,
which was very,
very cool,
I thought.
But the last day he always talked to us like put dopes the last 30 minutes we
actually walk guys.
I mean,
you're going to be standing there with your fucking head up your ass.
I'd so want to sit there and be like,
you realize men built this hospital and all major medicine was because of men.
I'm just saying they took every fucking thing when it comes to the male and
female dynamic,
when they talk about the guy,
if there's a woman running it,
the shit that they say,
they always talk to us like we're fucking stupid.
The exact fucking thing that all these broads who are feminists say they don't
want done to them happens all the time to us all the fucking time.
Hmm.
Okay.
And look at you.
You could care less the same way.
I don't give a shit that you make a dollar less an hour than I do to go down to
the Laverne and Shirley plant and put little caps on those beer bottles.
Jamil schmozzle what does that mean in Yiddish?
Oh,
I don't know.
Is that,
is it Yiddish?
Yeah,
I love Yiddish.
I don't know a she meals that guy.
He's the kind of guy who goes out to a restaurant.
He spills some soup.
A schmozzle.
I think that's how you say he's the guy who spills it on.
That is right.
It is.
You want to,
Oh,
you want to bet?
Sure.
You want to,
how much you want bet bills,
soup.
I swear to God.
Bill,
how much you want to put some fucking clothes?
I so I'm standing up now.
No,
but that Rove just can not be contained.
Containment.
What?
Uh,
how much you want to bet?
I don't know.
10 Bucks.
All right.
Let's look it up right now.
We're talking about the baby low jack.
Third 30 minutes of it as we walked around the hospital.
Oh yeah.
They got these little,
these little fucking,
he showed us some newborns and it was so cute.
But they have a,
they have a security in place these days for babies,
which I did not know a little ankle bracelet on the thing like,
like it was on house arrest just in case somebody came into the hospital and
started stealing babies,
which I've never fucking heard of that Everett,
that it's slowly getting you used to having that thing now.
It's just on their ankle.
Oh boom.
[inaudible] and then eventually it's fucking in a,
I mean,
Tony,
take it off.
It's not like that's all when baby steps,
baby steps your baby.
Step your way into someone.
They have an id tag on one ankle and then they have a little
okay.
Ankle bracelet on the other to keep track of them.
Are you actually,
are you googling Shamiel schmozzle yeah.
I'm going to get one one when my fucking 10 bucks.
Okay.
All right.
Seeing how wrong you are.
Oh God.
I cannot wait for you to find the fucking page because I looked it up.
You're awfully comfortable.
I mean,
you're awfully confidence,
so I'm starting to think whatever money you want to fucking bet.
It's only 10 bucks.
All right,
here we go.
Shamiel schmozzle office Bevin Hyphens,
Pfeffer incorporated.
Uh,
did the,
uh,
we're gonna do
way give his age.
Jeff Shamiel schmozzle are to Yiddish terms,
often used in comical,
but sometimes biting sense of humor.
Um,
uh,
Shamiel is somebody who opt in,
spills his soup,
and a Shamaz will is the person that lands on,
ah,
wow.
I owe you $10 pay up.
Fucking he pay up.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
That's $10.
Tell you what,
you can keep that $10.
I know you put its words and fucking robe.
It's cloaked.
Uh,
you paid me to the punch.
I was going to say I'd give you a $10.
I'll let you keep your $10 and I have to do those dumb ass jobs.
Um,
all right,
there you go.
This has been the full frontal podcast.
Um,
oh my God.
Oh,
stop it.
You still fucking dramatic.
It's just a God damn cough.
I'm inside.
There's heat and I have aspirin.
I'm going to be fine.
The bill burn memorial podcasts for be Monday.
Oh,
speaking of that,
speaking of a,
you know,
I'm in my forties.
I have a lot of friends that are no longer here.
I got a couple of benefits to promote,
uh,
p common.
Um,
this Tuesday,
great friend of mine unfortunately passed away,
uh,
bought a month ago and uh,
we're having a benefit for him.
Eight o'clock at the laugh factory.
I'm going to be doing a bunch of time trying out of all this new stuff.
We're going to have a great time.
And I'm,
he really was,
you know,
92 to 99.
He was just somebody I saw,
like practically almost every day.
And we had so many great gigs before he went into writing and all that type of
stuff.
So it's an honor to do something in his memory,
um,
for,
uh,
as is wonderful kids.
Um,
and then we have the Patrice O'Neal benefit.
You know,
yesterday was the five year anniversary.
Can you believe that?
Wow.
I can't believe I haven't talked to him in five years.
That's crazy.
I'm been trashed by him.
Heard him laughing.
Oh yeah.
And think of everything that happened.
I remember when,
when he speaking of sent Dusky right after he died was when all of that shit
came out.
And I just remember
just trying to imagine what he would have been talking about and I know that his
angle,
somehow he would've made,
he would have made that absolutely hilarious.
Um,
but anyways,
uh,
the next benefit is,
um,
Tuesday,
February 21st,
um,
tickets as always have been and been going along steadily.
It makes a great Christmas gift.
Ladies,
if you want to get something for your husband,
um,
it's going to be Leslie Jones,
Gary Gulman,
Dan Soder,
Jim Norton,
Rich Vos,
Bobby Kelly,
myself,
Keith Robinson.
I think I got everybody.
We always try to have an eight or nine people.
Um,
it's such a,
Oh,
I'm so bummed I'm going to miss it.
I'm going to miss a Leslie Jones.
Oh,
she's going to Marie,
I love to hear,
do you stand up?
I better not be going on after,
uh,
can I just say being in the Green Room at tough crowd with Colin Quinn,
with Patrice,
like,
I dunno,
like two times a week is probably the most like fun.
I lacked every single day on that job and he was definitely him.
Geraldo,
you know,
we're such like a big part of that.
And like,
I dunno,
it's just having Patrice around saying the most offensive,
like a horrible,
horrible things that you can say as a man to a woman.
But they were always funny,
like I can't deny the fact that like,
I'd be like,
fuck you,
but I would be so funny at the same time.
It's like,
that's the infuriating thing about comedians.
it's like you guys say the most fucked up shit,
but it's so funny.
So it's hard to stay mad at you.
So we just fucking around.
I know.
No,
and it's all in,
it's all like,
whatever you do shouldn't be laughing at this.
But it's so fun.
You want a red classic comedians story.
Real cause it David tells story.
So we're at fucking standup New York and there was a little person in the room,
right?
A little person in the comedy club.
And I think I kind of just fucked the whole thing up.
Right.
Was there.
So the fucking club owner was all like,
you know,
okay,
there's a,
you know,
it's a little person is,
at the show tonight,
let's not make any joke with Bob Blasco,
so everybody's not doing jokes and stuff,
blah,
blah.
And he says,
it's to Dave Attell.
Dave just goes,
AH,
okay.
Yeah.
Right.
And he walks right up on stage and me,
first thing in his mouth,
he just goes,
I understand.
We have a little man in the room.
Yeah.
Whole place labs.
The dude laughed.
Ah,
sorry.
Sorry.
I
just went red line that he fucking laughed any fucking set all of this shit and
the guy loved it and had a great fucking time.
Yeah.
And I,
I dunno man,
I was just one of those things where I'm at.
I was brand new when I saw him do that,
like to meet up to just disobey an order from a New York City club owner.
I was like,
oh my God.
And he's still gonna get spots.
If I went a minute over where I was on the,
on the ladder at that point,
if I went over like one fucking minute,
um,
David tell at a bunch of those that he did the gator growl one time,
which is you went down to the swamp,
which is like this fucking with the gators play football and um,
you were supposed to work squeaky clean.
The,
uh,
Dean didn't want you to fucking say anything dirty.
Brewer told me this story.
It's another one.
I'm going to fuck up and cough my way through.
Sit.
Everybody works.
Squeaky clean.
And he was sitting there wondering how David Tell was going to handle it.
And Dave came out and just did the most filthy as fucking joke from his act
right up front.
And then looked right over at the,
at the whole board of the things.
And he goes,
fuck you Dane.
This one's for this students.
And the whole place went fucking nuts.
And then he murdered for like a half hour and then I coughed myself to death.
All right.
I gotta put some clothes on.
Oh,
Billy Ball valve.
Hopefully Paul second.
You cough your robe.
Opens this a little bit more.
Well,
you know what,
Nia,
you got to tease the crowd a little.
All right.
That's the podcast for Thursday.
Have a great weekend.
You conch.
Um,
and I'll talk to you on Monday there.
[inaudible]
um,
anyways,
new pope a Boston.
Billy loved the podcast.
Keep up the good work.
Thank you.
What do you make of all this news about the pope retiring?
Oh Geez.
Personally,
I'm not that religious and don't really care that much.
Maybe if they elected a new pope that was young,
well that was a young,
some young hot lady in her twenties I would give a shit.
What do you think bill?
Is there more to the story that,
that they're not telling us where his age and health issues.
The only reason he retired is the church covering anything up.
Um,
I'll come on do it.
Are they covering anything up?
They fucking have been an aisle.
Certain percentage of them have been covering up other fucking kids
for a long time.
You know,
during World War Two there was a,
you know,
they got in bed with the Nazis.
I mean,
it really is one of the worst organization as far as some of the shit that
they've done,
you know,
but people are so wrapped into not pissing off the invisible guy in wanting to
go to the happy place and get to eat marshmallows for the rest of your fall.
Fucking eternity that they are actually,
it's really,
it's,
it's disturbing
that people can still be part of that religion.
Do you know what I mean?
I,
I don't understand how,
you know,
the stuff that they've done.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I would say,
there's probably something going on.
I don't know.
Maybe he said something like,
Hey,
you know,
uh,
maybe we should apologize for,
having that clam bake with Adolf Hitler.
Should we maybe clear the air with that one?
Hey,
what do you say?
Yah.
We actually don't help to pay for the lawyers of the people in our organization
who put their dicks in the asses of kids.
You know,
maybe he said something like,
I have no idea.
Anyways,
she said also,
what are some of some of the ways that they could make the church more
interesting?
For example,
maybe let broads become a priest.
I bet more people would pay attention.
Or how about letting people sit in the lazy boys instead of sitting and kneeling
and those terrible rock hard benches they call pews.
I know,
it's so dumb.
The whole thing is to get you like you're not worthy.
You're not worthy.
Get on your fucking knees and it's in,
it's all,
it's all made up by human beings taking a guess and,
and other adults because they get into it as kids.
They,
they,
I don't know why.
I actually know why,
because I believe that there was like a spirituality and I believe that you feel
good when you do good things.
And I just think that you can't corral that nobody owns it and you can't put a
fucking,
like,
I think that all churches should just be philosophies rather than this,
this hardened way of looking at things.
Um,
just the amount of deaths that it has caused.
I don't,
I'm not saying anything fucking,
do you guys know how I feel in this shit?
Um,
finally,
how about we live in up the music a bit and add some newer sounds.
Maybe a little guitar and drums.
Well,
what you need to do is go to a Baptist church,
go to a church where you don't see any white people going in there.
Um,
the,
that would be a good one to start with and I bet you amazing.
You'll,
you'll hear people who are actually in those churches probably sing bay better
than half the people who won grammys that year.
I mean,
how many times you've seen some amazing created whore sticking her finger in a
year loud,
trying to act like they know how to sing and what are they,
what's behind them all the fucking time.
It's always like fucking three black chicks or two black chicks to some black
dude.
I mean,
that's where the music is.
That's where it's coming from.
If that's what you want,
just fucking go there.
They're not going to give a shit.
Right.
They might look at you weird,
but after a while I wants to see you feel in the music.
You should be fine.
The rest of the shit.
I Dunno.
I think that they should maybe update the stories
every once in awhile.
Maybe.
Uh,
just make up some new shit.
Just say,
Oh,
you know what God,
God came back again and the burning Bush said,
uh,
you know,
let he who never a illegally downloaded the song.
Just something to fucking update it.
I don't know what to tell you.
You know what I mean?
I don't know.
Updated,
I guess,
you know,
there are some sort of,
some of those new age,
the new age ones that just as scary because then somehow somebody always ends up
saying there,
Jesus,
and the next thing you know,
you're surrounded by the FBI and his tanks shooting flames at you,
or you're waiting for some aliens to come.
And next thing you know,
everybody's drinking some poison and you die in a fucking bunk bed,
you know,
or in the middle of the jungle with some sweaty fucking Congo player,
whatever the fucking that guy's name was.
You know,
I think better is when it comes to a spirituality and that type of shit.
I think you're really,
you're better off on your own.
Um,
I think,
you know,
I think generally speaking,
if you're not a psycho,
you kind of know how to be a decent human being.
I'm not saying that you're always succeed in it.
I certainly don't.
But,
um,
I don't know how the fuck do I put it.
I would rather sit at a bar about six,
seven beers in and talk to somebody else who is in the same mind frame and talk
about life than I would to actually go to a church and listen to some guy up
there going.
And then he did shop there.
Gaddy did shop thing.
Aus.
Hey did it for you.
He died painfully.
I hope you appreciated the ally little.
Yeah,
we,
we are.
You are not fucking worthy.
We want you to remember this.
Your a piece of shit.
You better hope he's not mad at you that way Lou.
Yeah.
Hallelujah.
I mean,
who the fuck wants to sit there through that?
I mean there's still telling stories about lepers.
Can we fucking update it?
You know,
the world was flat and other world is flat and there was some lappers and a guy
at a big is stuck some animals on,
what am I singing?
I don't even know.
Well,
I shouldn't have listened to my mother like,
do you?
How do you end up in that?
Okay,
here's a job where you,
you're not going to be able to ever fuck another woman again.
You know?
Yeah.
Well do I get a wife now?
You don't get that.
You're going to sit in this dorm room with a bunch of other guys.
None of you are we going to are going to get any pussy whatsoever.
Okay.
There you go.
There's a natural,
like the whole thing is just like as far as the Catholic way is just like,
just flogging yourself.
Do you understand how fucked up,
but you got one fucking life.
You should be out having the time of your life,
you know,
not hurting anybody but having the time you life and enjoying it because you
fucking deserve it because you were lucky enough to be born a human being and
not a fucking house fly.
What if reincarnation is true?
All right,
and you're going to fucking come back.
Is is a,
uh,
I don't know.
Something is snakies.
What else?
Little fucking lizards sitting at darting around.
Even if you don't get eaten by a snake,
you only live like 14 days.
You can fucking drive a car.
You know,
you never see a lizard doing that shit.
Do you
sleep?
Battled Scottish Cardinal.
Oh,
Brian.
Cardinal O'brien apologizes for my sexual conduct.
You know,
I'm getting sick of people apologizing for shit,
and they dance around this guy basically to use my new word,
he buggered some kids.
All right?
He took out his holy Cock Oleo and stuck it in their fucking,
uh,
what the fuck was Jesus born in a shed?
What are they always call it?
You know what are always around Christmas.
I remember what it's called.
What was he?
He was born in a barn,
but they give it some biblical,
what's the name for a Biblical Barn?
I don't give a fuck.
Anyways,
it says a Scottish cardinal who had earlier earlier challenged allegations of
his sexual impropriety,
claims that once again claims that once again shine an international spotlight
in the alleged alleged sexual abuse evolving involving Roman Catholic clergy
reverse course Sunday.
And the guy,
I apologize,
this is how he apologizes for basically I,
for as far as I can tell,
fucking children in the ass.
He said,
I wished to take this opportunity to admit that there have been times that my
sexual conduct has fallen below the standards expected of me as a priest,
archbishop and Cardinal.
In recent days,
certain allegations which have been made against me have become public
initially.
There are anonymous and nonspecific nature led me to contest them to those I
have offended.
I apologize and ask forgiveness to those.
I've offended.
You know,
I've been lucky enough in my life to have never been unwantedly fucking banged
in the ass by fucking priest.
But I know I think I can be empathetic enough and say that if this was
happening,
at no point would I be turning around going,
you know,
that's what you're doing is really offensive.
I find this,
you know what the fuck.
When you apologize,
you should have to say what the fuck you did.
And if you're going to talk like this,
there should be somebody of noxious Lee yelling off the Mike like what you did
like during this apology should have been like and wish to take this opportunity
to admit the tariff and time that might actual conduct has fallen below the
standards expected of me as a priest.
Yeah.
And it's a fucking human being.
You're not supposed to fuck kids in recent days,
certain allegations fucking of children which have been made against me have
become public Bob flock and tide.
Initially there were anonymous and nonspecific nature led me to contest them.
How many different ways to we up explain it.
You talk to your fucking Dick to put in there.
You got the point.
Um,
good lord to those.
I have offended to those you're raped.
You're a fucking rapist.
And like,
like how like he tries to tie in the fact that he's a priest.
Stay like below the standards expected of me as a priest,
Archbishop,
archbishop and Cardinal.
So like
what if you,
if you were a pope that was okay.
Or is it because you never became a pope?
So this guy basically been dental in kids ever since he got into that fucking
hurt.
How is that thing still in business is just fucking do it.
[inaudible] Hey,
what's going on?
No,
nope.
Monday morning podcasts that I'm actually doing this week on a Sunday just
because tomorrow.
Um,
I have to uh,
have to be on set.
Yeah,
look at me.
Big Time Hollywood guy.
Sorry people.
I don't have time for you tomorrow.
I have to be on set.
Uh,
you liked that for a,
I'm actually shooting,
I'm shooting something tomorrow,
so I gotta do that tomorrow.
There you go.
You like,
you like how I worked at in,
you guys didn't even ask me.
I didn't have to tell you.
I'm one of those guys.
I arrogantly work my resume into every sort of conversation.
Do you think it's going to rain tomorrow?
Well,
you know,
when I was taping,
I love the 80s.
They were telling me that tomorrow it's supposed to,
you know,
people do that and then you want to fucking do something violent or maybe,
maybe not,
maybe not.
Maybe people aren't like me.
It makes you realize what a fucking angry asshole I am.
Um,
on a whole nother level.
This past month,
I just,
uh,
I'm just really,
difficult to be around and,
um,
that's it.
See Ya,
it's a fucking pretty hardcore moment to have with yourself.
Stay yourself in the mirror and to be like,
dude,
if I could somehow walk out of this fucking situation,
I would,
and I was supposed to be here with you.
So,
um,
anyways,
I hope everybody had an,
uh,
a nice,
happy thanksgiving.
I hope you had a good time.
And,
uh,
I had a great one and a,
I fucked up last week though.
I was,
I had done basically like,
you know,
seven attempts at this podcast and uh,
trying to make sure I was thanking everybody and I totally fucked up on the
seventh take.
And I forgot to thank uh,
Michael Hanes,
the uh,
the announcer for the Colorado avalanche.
A Guy I met on the road,
whoever dental,
he likes my comedy and found out I was a hockey fan.
So the e the fuck it avalanche.
We're playing the kings hooked me up with some tickets and interviewed me in
between periods.
You know,
like I was fucking Diane Cannon at a Laker game.
it's sort of a drop off with celebrity when you go,
when you go to the La Kings game,
you know,
you go to La Laker game,
you know who you're going to get.
You know you got Jack Nicholson,
fucking will Smith,
all those guys.
Even if you go to a clippers game,
Billy crystal sits court side along with that black dude from a different world
and where that guy with the glasses,
the round John Lennon glasses.
But when you go to a kings game,
now that John Candy died,
actually,
when did he die?
He died a long time ago.
But ever since he died,
the only kings like that that's like,
it's classic La.
When Gretzky showed up then on and all the fucking people came out,
you know,
and then he leaves and John Candy dies.
That was sort of a combo,
you know,
boom,
boom.
And everyone was like,
fucking,
I'm not gonna go there.
So now,
what am I trying to say here?
I'm trying to say that if they yank a celebrity out of the fucking stands at a
kings game,
you're going to get somebody at my level,
basically a non celebrity who hasn't had the decency to at least become fat or
an addict.
So you can enjoy me on a reality show.
I am a responsible,
semi noticeable human being who pays his bills on time.
And if that isn't compelling,
I don't know what it is.
I actually know somebody went to the La Kings game one time a long time ago,
back at the La Forum and I saw,
uh,
I saw,
why am I thinking Mike Adam Lee?
It's not Mike Adam Lee.
That was the host of NFL 81 let's Bryant Gumbel.
I'm totally going.
Who's the fucking guy who did a e Jesus Christ.
He was the amounts of when,
uh,
the miracle on ice,
Michael Al Michaels,
Jesus Christ,
they go al Michaels was there,
big fan of hockey.
I saw him and I really wanted to say something too,
but he had,
I could see it in the wrinkles in his forehead that he was like,
I know,
I know you like me,
but please I'm here with my kid.
And I was like,
all right.
And we set it all with the wrinkles on our foreheads.
Pretty amazing moment.
You know,
I've always had that kind of connection with people to be,
you know,
uh,
communicate through the third eye.
Um,
all right.
If you new to my podcast,
where the fuck have you been?
Huh?
I've been doing them for over a year,
you know?
No.
Now what you jumping on the bandwagon because I'm finally over 20 listeners,
you know,
because I actually got a compliment today from somebody in a jolly old England.
I got something in England listening to this shit.
He liked that.
I'm on two different continents,
so it's not numbers,
it's not the amount of people you have listening to your podcast.
It's the amount of,
of uh,
of countries.
All right,
look at me.
I'm going global just like everybody else,
just like everybody else.
So,
uh,
so anyways,
um,
can I really do the podcast and I'll talk about the guy who got trampled at
Walmart.
I mean,
if it's just fucking unbelievable,
I just don't,
I,
you know,
how bad is the fucking economy that,
some guy opening the door to a fucking store that sells garbage cans,
shack it's,
and fucking rakes gets trampled to death.
What the fuck were those people run it for?
I Dunno.
I like how they tried to say people broke down on the door.
I really don't think they did.
I think that they were being pressed up against it.
If you're first in line,
why are you going to break down the door?
You know,
think about that analogy.
You want to be extra first.
That doesn't make any sense.
People were pushing from behind.
They basically created a,
they had general seating like the who in Cincinnati.
He can't fucking do that shit.
And for years we were right every,
every year at Christmas,
you see the doors,
they burst open.
There's was always a big black girl loses her fucking wig.
When she falls on the ground,
there's always that dirty white dude with the wranglers and one of his pant legs
gets ripped off as he tries to come in through the overnight mailbox.
You know,
it was inevitable.
It was fucking inevitable.
What a Goddamn way to go.
That's absolutely fucking tragic.
And I don't even know why I brought it up.
I just,
I can't get over it.
I can't get over that.
Somebody died doing that.
You know
how you supposed to die at Walmart?
You know?
I don't know.
Maybe you stocking the shelves.
You just come fucking slamming down on that linoleum floor.
Even then coma benefit,
you know,
you get to meet the local sports hero.
You know,
you're out on long island build Garren comes in and signs of
Fucking Island Jersey.
It's just fucking,
you know,
you're not supposed to die at Walmart.
That's just,
that's like a really,
I don't know.
What do you guys think about that?
Do you think Walmart is at fault there?
He me for years.
You know,
I don't,
I don't know who's at fault there.
I mean,
Walmart,
you know,
they come into the town,
they basically fucking fuck over every small business there.
Now,
I've met all those people with small business owners.
They don't have any fucking money now.
So now they pressed up against the glass.
Oh my God,
I need to get a rake.
[inaudible] $3.
It's fucking nine,
nine.
Open the doors.
I mean,
they literally created that fucking thing.
Jesus Christ.
Well,
why don't I read before I do these?
I really built it.
They literally created what in your head?
You fucking moron.
All right,
let's get to the podcast questions.
Like I said,
if you're new to my podcast,
people send me questions.
Uh,
they send me comments.
They,
uh,
they try to educate me on certain things and I them,
but it doesn't happen so much that way because I'm a moron.
So let's get to the first question of the week.
Question number one.
Boy Did I even think Michael Hanes?
Yeah.
So Michael,
thank you very much for putting me on in between periods,
man.
It was a,
uh,
it was unbelievable.
And uh,
they actually let me,
hey gimme,
Peter McNabb let me hang out as the game started.
And I really realized how hard it is to tell stories as you're watching the
game.
Like I couldn't even focus and I actually talked over a goal.
I was really in the middle of telling a story during a breakaway and I didn't
even,
I'm so into trying to be funny on TV.
I didn't notice that it was like a fucking two on one and then the guys scored.
So I had to cut my story short by saying,
oops.
I was like,
yeah.
And then my dad was crazy.
Oops.
That's what I literally said.
On national television.
At that point I wanted to crawl out of the studio,
but it was still awesome.
Anyways.
All right,
here we go.
Podcast question of the week.
Question number one bill,
have you ever been confronted by midgets about your bit midgets or done it in
front of midgets?
Um,
actually,
uh,
I had a,
I had a small person whenever you supposed to call them,
send me an email.
And the bit was basically,
I don't understand why the word midget is offensive,
you know,
it's not like midgets would dragged here from another country,
packed into a boat,
you know,
the whole [inaudible] thing and then fucking forced to,
uh,
you know,
have them in 38 of their friends crawl out of a car in the middle of a circus.
You know,
I did jokes like that,
you know,
I don't understand.
You know,
it's just the word.
That's the table.
That's the lamp and you're a midget.
That's how the joke went.
Plus,
Mitch,
it sounds tough.
I'm a fucking midget,
you know,
but then this guy,
actually a little person actually wrote me and said,
actually midget is offensive because it came,
I guess somebody on Barnum Bailey came up with it and it,
it's actually a form of the word and Mitch,
which I guess is some sort of little bug so it somehow came out of that.
So you basically say midget,
you're saying that they're just a little,
little bug that you could just step on or maybe tear one of their legs off and
watch them run around in a circle?
So yeah,
it is.
So I have been confronted,
um,
you know,
some,
like last night somebody did a joke about a dwarf and there was a,
I think a little person in the crowd.
And,
uh,
I looked over at him,
so their face,
you know,
sort of crinkle up a little bit,
like even on a holiday weekend,
I have to deal with this.
And I felt a little bad for them.
I try not to look at the crowd when I talk because,
uh,
you know,
I got a lot of shit that could bug people.
Can I answer that?
Okay.
Question note to bill.
I want to be a standup comedian.
Do you want to be a standup comedian?
Sure.
We all do.
We hear it to Vraie.
Um,
okay.
Dave said on insight,
I'm assuming this is Chappelle sent on inside the actor's studio that if you
want to be a standup comedian,
you have to take acting lessons.
Did you take acting lessons?
Uh,
yes I have.
Although you would never know it if you ever saw me act.
Thank you.
Um,
yeah,
I've taken acting lessons and uh,
I haven't taken him on a while,
but,
um,
I dunno why.
I Dunno why I stopped taking acting lessons.
Why did I,
you don't mind cause I hated the classes.
They were too fucking long and then I was always,
um,
I dunno.
I was,
it was always like that one person who,
who uh,
who sucks so bad that it made me want to quit the class.
You know,
we used to call them bathroom,
bathroom break guy.
Like,
you know,
like when they went up to do their scene,
you went to go take a bathroom break.
But I would tell you this,
if you do,
you want to become a comedian.
I mean,
I don't know if actually helps you stand up or not,
but I know it definitely helps you when you get to the next level of this
business when you have to shoot something like I do tomorrow,
that a,
if you've taken acting lessons that you had,
you know,
you actually know how to do it.
So,
um,
I mean if you want to be a comedian,
just write five minutes of shit you think's funny.
Sign up for an open mic and when they call your name,
go up there.
Um,
you know,
you'll be fine.
You don't have to recite Shakespeare.
But um,
as you get going along,
I would definitely take acting classes,
improv classes for as much as comedians make fun of it.
Improv classes really help you.
Uh,
I think an acting because you're literally improving with other,
another person in stand up is so solitary.
You're just standing on stage in private with the crowd,
but it's still all you and you don't really have to wait for someone else.
I could go on forever.
About this shit.
So yeah,
right.
Five minutes of Shit you think's funny and um,
sign up for an open mic and then you know when she get that thing going,
take,
take anything.
Sketch,
sketch,
class as many things as you could learn.
I would,
you know,
I mean the amount of times I've kicked myself for not learning how to tap dance.
I mean I just can't tell no kid.
I was just thinking back to the Vaudeville days when you had to be a triple
threat.
Funny.
Be able to dance and sing before it became,
you know,
it's like the NFL,
you just,
I just play on special teams,
you know,
I'm the long snapper you ever see like football teams back in the 20s they had
like eight guys on them.
All right.
Question number three.
Tonight me and my friends were having,
and we're having an argument about ACDC,
he was saying how Angus young is hands down the coolest mother fucking guitar
player of all time.
While I agree with that,
I just think it's time for him to lose the schoolboy outfit.
I mean,
isn't the dude like approaching 60,
believe it or not,
Angus is only 53 years old.
He made it when he was like 19 or 20.
He was born in 1955.
Malcolm young was born in 1953 and bond Scott I believe was born in 1946.
Okay.
I just established that I'm a geek.
Now let's get back to ACDC.
You know what I gotta agree with you.
I think a actually read an article recently where he was talking about,
Angus was talking about having to put on that schoolboy outfit and he said,
and quote unquote,
I have to become that guy.
But,
um,
I don't know.
That's a very like I would totally,
What would it look like if Angus actually put some jeans on and started bouncing
around the stage like that?
It would definitely take a minute.
But you're really fucking with,
uh,
the whole formula and ACDC is formula has never wavered.
They're like,
we're singing about balls,
the devil and Pussy and drinking,
and they have not veered away from that for over 33 years.
So,
I mean,
I don't know if you put pants on as the whole house of cards come down.
I think it would take a minute,
but I wouldn't have a problem.
I wouldn't have a problem you can put pants on.
I really would not have a problem with it.
Um,
you know what they should do?
They should do an ACDC unplugged where they still play electric.
But Angus gets to sit down and around with all the other band members.
Kind of like an Elvis has come back special where it was still like electric.
Well Mama,
remember that one?
All right.
Um,
all right,
question number four.
So don't even answer that.
Do I think it's time to like,
I wouldn't bother me,
but I can definitely see why he continues to wear that outfit because a,
I wouldn't want to fuck with that formula.
So podcast question number four.
Hey Bill,
I signed up for your email list.
Uh,
thanks for the confirmation email.
Very corporate like,
yeah,
fuck you.
Like I got a guy running my website a little bit.
What do you want from me?
You know,
we,
we basically have,
you know,
my email list on my website.
Basically what happens is people who have an AOL email,
if two of them mark you as spam,
you get kicked off the Internet.
So I'm trying to get rid of all the,
all people who don't want me.
That's why I sent that out.
Okay.
And that's why we confirmed it.
Anyways,
he says I'm 19 and I haven't had sex since 2006.
Jesus Christ.
Where's this going?
When I was 16 years old,
well,
first of all,
I'm not sympathetic because I didn't lose my virginity until I was fucking 19.
Um,
I dunno what the Hell's going on.
And I wanted to know how long your longest dry streak was and how you ended it.
Well,
I just ruined the joke the first 19 years of my life on how did I end it?
I met some chick who sang in a band who was fucking about 37 years old and I
think you can fill in the blanks.
Um,
okay,
well I know what you're saying.
Once,
once I was in the game,
what's the longest I went?
Uh,
I think the first fucking year and a half,
maybe two years of my comedy career,
I
swear to God I was finishing college,
I was living in a home with my parents and I was doing stand up at night.
I mean I barely had time to rub one out.
Not to mention I had like,
you know,
people say I had,
I have no game with women if you know,
and technically there's no way to be lower than ground zero.
Somehow I was,
I was below,
I was below ground zero.
Have no game with women to the point like,
do you ever hear the end of whole lot of love when Robert Plant's sings the echo
of what he's about ready to sing comes first to indicate that he's in hell.
That's like when I would hit on girls,
the echo of the awful line that I was going to say to them that that would come
out first.
And then my awful.
So they were already walking away before I opened my mouth.
So probably about two years.
So what do you won?
You're about two years.
Yeah,
but dude,
you know,
some,
I know another comic,
he got laid at like 14.
He didn't get laid again until he was like 18.
Um,
don't worry about it,
you know?
Um,
how can you get out of it?
It's just,
it's a numbers game.
Just,
you know what?
Rub One out before you go out.
So that takes the pressure off.
Now you don't give a shit and then just go out there and uh,
start saying the shit that your brain is telling you.
Not to say like don't say that that will offender.
That's the kind of shit you need to start saying.
I mean,
I don't mean walk up to her and just be like a,
Hey,
what's up?
You fucking cunt.
And
I'm not saying say that.
I'm just saying that,
you know what I mean?
I can't even think of a fucking example.
Just,
I don't know.
You just,
you know,
you start steering the conversation towards sex and when she acts like she's
offended,
just tell her that she's not offended,
you know?
You know,
you just do that shit.
You just keep [inaudible] it's one of those things you just have to learn.
You have to learn what your style of being an asshole is.
This is if you're going to try and get late.
If you want to meet the woman of your dreams,
don't do that.
Then you have to,
I guess listen to your heart.
I have no idea.
Wow.
That just made me feel creepy.
Um,
which is probably why not married.
Okay.
Um,
all right,
let's move along.
Okay.
Question number five.
Thank you.
You thank you.
In a large capital letters,
they're like,
I forgot the word capital,
so I had st large so I could buy time and my brain to come up with capital
capital's okay.
Um,
I'm so tired of people trashing conspiracy theory.
All this was last week.
Why defendant can sips conspiracy theory.
I'm so tired of people trashing conspiracy theory without looking into it.
I'm not saying that all of the theories of valid,
but I also think people have a tendency to be,
to be questionless sheep.
I just want to say thank you for telling those fucks to think for themselves a
bit.
Um,
yeah,
I mean it wasn't going that hardcore.
Yeah.
But I definitely think,
yeah,
people just,
yeah.
If it's on TV,
it's true.
If it's on the Internet then it's the,
that's the Internet's were all the lies are,
it's kind of like racism,
like all the racist white people are just in the south,
but everybody in Connecticut is cool,
you know,
those,
that type of mindset.
Anyway,
here's this question.
Why aren't you coming to Chicago anytime soon?
Make it happen is all I'm saying.
Jesus Christ.
All right.
I'm very demanding.
Um,
while I was there in March when me and I don't know where the hell you are,
there's a lot of cities out there.
I try to come through about once a year.
Chicago is definitely on my,
uh,
it's like a politician right now.
Yeah,
we're definitely looking into the that and it's definitely on the agenda and
when the time is right,
we're going to handle the situation in Chicago Nets.
Next question please.
All right,
Bill,
how many emails do you get with the word dude in the subject?
Probably a shit ton.
Here's another one.
Deal with it.
You know,
so I think people are starting to feed off my attitude where you guys are being
assholes to me for no reason.
Kind of like how I'm assholes to people who ask me questions for no reason.
All right,
Bill,
I was making my breakfast in my 900 square foot,
$450,000 condo this morning attempting to determine what a,
which octane of gasoline I was going to use to burn down my bank.
Okay.
And then finally,
this bailout ass raping,
uh,
really clicked.
I mean I knew we were getting bent over the table on this whole deal,
but not in such an obvious manner.
Our government is taking our money via taxes,
giving it to bank so they can loan us our own money back and interest that
fucking taking our money so they can loan it back to us for more money.
And the cock mitigating ass clowns in Washington are all voting yes on this
shit.
How the fuck did this happen?
Um,
I mean I don't,
I don't know.
I'm not in the Senate,
but I would imagine that if you print the money,
you have enough money to pay off politicians.
So they basically do whatever the banks want them to do.
I mean,
I dunno.
It's,
it's brutal.
I'm trying to get out from underneath the house of Rothschild joined to get out
from underneath the red shield.
That's what I'm doing.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know what to tell you do.
How do they do it?
Because the other guys running shit.
And uh,
if you can just print,
what would you do if you could print money,
you know,
and everybody accepted the money that you are printing.
I mean,
I
could you handle that level of power.
I couldn't,
you know,
and what if your job depending on,
dependent on doing what those guys wanted you to do.
I mean they will right above you.
I guess you would do it right.
I have no idea.
You know?
That's fascinating.
That's like I said,
like those,
that's like one of those will Smith summer blockbuster movie kind of plots.
I don't know why they're voting yes on it.
I think some are voting yes on it because they want to keep their positions.
I don't think other people are voting yes on it cause they don't really
understand it.
Kind of like make like you just think,
well if we owe $1 billion,
why don't they just print $1 billion and just pay it off?
And the reason is because
I guess you still owe the money to the bank because the Federal Reserve
Princeton and you've got to pay interest on the billion dollars so you never get
out of debt.
I don't know.
I can't even fucking explain it anymore.
Probably sound like a moron,
which I am.
I've been reading meetings to read that book the case against the Federal
Reserve.
I really have been.
All right.
Question number seven.
Hey,
just wondering if you have a version of the aristocrats joke and what you
thought of that documentary pendulum made of it.
Um,
I don't think pen g,
I don't think Penn Jillette made that documentary.
I was a,
Oh my God,
it's for blank on his name was another comedian who made that.
Maybe I can Google it.
Um,
on anyways,
it's like Google this I MDB it.
Paul Paul Provenza,
he's the guy who made it.
Paul Provenza directed that.
Um,
anyways,
let me get back to the questions here.
I was like,
I have an incoming call.
I gotta wrap this podcast up here.
All right.
What did I think about,
do I have a version?
Do I have a version of the aristocrats jokes?
No,
I don't,
and I never heard of that joke until I saw the,
uh,
the documentary on it.
I bet in a lot of green rooms and in 16 years coming up on 17 years of doing
stand up,
I've never,
I never even heard the joke.
So,
uh,
but I thought I liked the movie.
I thought it was funny and Bob Saget was my favorite because he seemed to be the
guy.
Like he was improving so much that he was making himself laugh at all the filthy
ship that he was coming up with.
Um,
and yeah,
if you haven't seen it,
I would definitely rent it cause I think it's a funny,
funny documentary.
There you go.
And it's Paul Provenza not pendula.
All right.
And I didn't even look that up,
but I,
I'm pretty sure that's true.
All right.
Question.
Are you drinking again so that I can buy you a beer when you come to Tampa?
Yes,
I am.
I am drinking again.
That's the name of my neck.
Stand up.
Special Bill bird drinking again.
I'm going to come on stage completely shit face and just fucking berate people.
I'm glad to see that you're finally coming by the way.
And what better time than January.
Well,
what happens in Tampa in January?
I guess I'm getting out of the winter.
Um,
alright.
Overrated.
Underrated.
Before I wrap up this podcast,
overrated.
Barack Obama.
Seriously,
the guy was senator for two years and he hasn't even taken office yet.
And people think he's the second coming.
I'm not hating on the man,
but I'm not ready to worship him yet.
Um,
well I think a lot of it has to do with,
uh,
you know,
just the last eight years have been a little rough without getting too
political,
you know,
I mean,
George Bush literally should have been doing speeches with a flashlight under
his chin.
He was so busy scaring the shit out of people for the last eight fucking years.
I think it's just going to be a relief to have somebody come in,
uh,
you know,
Jesus Christ.
Just somebody different,
somebody different.
But yeah,
I mean,
then then will do this,
you know,
just feel good thing.
Yeah.
We elected a black guy.
That means we're not as ugly a country as we were before.
You know,
I don't know.
I think everybody's life is in the shitter and they're just hoping that somebody
can do something.
But I definitely agree with you.
If you're waiting for one guy to take that office and to turn your life around
you,
uh,
you know,
it's kind of like when I get in this business,
you get a manager and an agent,
you're like,
well,
I guess I don't need to do any more work.
They just going to bring shit to me.
It doesn't work that way.
All right.
Underrated.
Playoff hockey.
Every round is so fucking intense.
And the fact that they play a seven game series makes the drama in the bad blood
continued for one game to the next.
Uh,
I would definitely say that I think the NHL package is underrated.
I have that.
Here's the last one and then I'm wrapping this up for this week.
Um,
overrated.
I love this one.
This is such a great one.
Overrated.
First Impressions.
Uh,
my first impressions are wrong.
Most of the time,
society needs to drop the significance of first impression.
There goes,
there goes me generalizing.
Maybe I'm,
I just have horrible judgment.
Now you don't,
I think that's great.
Yeah.
My first impressions are mostly wrong and people's first impressions of me,
a lot of times they're wrong.
Um,
I think they are.
Oh,
my girlfriend stared at me right now.
Like,
bullshit.
You know,
I fuck you.
It's true.
This is a deal.
You know what?
This is what,
this is what I found.
If you're a quiet person and you meet an in a,
uh,
an insecure person,
they misinterpret your quietness for arrogance and they start thinking,
this guy thinks he's fucking better than me,
then they think you're a Douche bag.
That's what people used to think of me before I became a loud mouth asshole and
removed all doubt that I am an arrogant cunt.
But a lot of shy people,
lot of people considered arrogant on are not arrogant.
They're fucking,
you know,
they're doing what I'm doing.
They're being quiet because they're questioning everything they did in the last
17 minutes.
I don't know if that even makes sense,
but I definitely think that's true because I've,
you know,
there's a number of people I thought were dicks when I first met him and it
turned out that I was the Dick.
And then there's been other people I've been like,
you know,
this guy's a cool fucking guy.
He's a real cool guy.
And then they turn out to be a complete psycho.
So,
uh,
I dunno,
I dunno what to tell you what that,
that's like that thing where would for every saying,
there's another saying that can fucking cancel it out.
Penny saved is a penny earned.
You've got to spend money to make money,
walk softly,
carry a big stick greasy wheel.
The squeaky wheel gets the grease,
you know what I mean?
Does that even make sense?
I don't fucking know.
Cause yeah,
your first impressions,
you know,
your mind might be wrong,
but then you gotta go with your gut.
You know,
that gut that says,
ah,
I shouldn't turn this trick because I think this person's going to snap my neck.
You know,
it's the prostitute that listens to that.
They're the ones they get to continue living the dream of sucking cock until
they're 55,
you know,
and finally having enough money to get out from underneath their pimp to go to
night school.
Those are the ones because they listened to that guy.
But I got admit,
yeah,
I would have to go with you on the first day that I mentioned I bought a
Credenza.
Can you believe that it's most adult thing I ever did.
I like looking at him pretending like I have some sort of official business to
do.
Um,
okay.
That's it.
And uh,
other than that,
um,
what do I got?
I got
Caroline Caroline's coming up this week.
I've got a brand new hour for you,
so all you bastards who are still full of Turkey,
um,
hit the fucking treadmill and come down to the club.
I've got a brand new hours,
shit that I'm really proud of and I'm putting it together and hopefully I'll be
taping another special next year so I can get on this doing a special every two,
two and a half years.
So I can have some sort of body of work at the end of this shit.
But I will not take any special before its time.
What fucking what a,
what?
Advertise.
And we will serve no wine before it's time.
Fuck was that.
I can't remember.
Anyways,
that's it.
Everybody have a good witch and,
uh,
keep the podcast questions coming and people keep asking me if I'm going to be
on Facebook.
Um,
I like my space,
you know what I mean?
I,
you know,
I like,
I gotta be loyal somewhere in my life.
I'm sticking it out with these fucking guys.
And,
uh,
you know,
I'm going to go through a couple of rough years with my space when,
when we looking like I'm still wearing bell bottoms,
but eventually it's gonna come back in style again and you guys can all be like,
oh yeah man,
I'm fucking back on my space again.
And I'd be like,
Oh yeah man.
Well I never fucking left.
So that means I'm cooler than you and that'll make me feel good for six minutes
before it become miserable again.
All right everybody,
thank you so much for listening to the podcast.
I hope you all have a great week.
Thanks again to Michael Hanes for letting me sit in on the ass game.
Sorry,
didn't thank you last week.
I fucking space cause I'm a moron.
And uh,
how about those Bruins?
Any hockey fans out there?
Any Canadian out there?
How can we not talking to any shit you like those two watts as you took it,
the hands and the Bruins this month.
How are you singing?
Jackasses
got damn at the fucking,
you got to respect the Canadians though.
I saw him the other night come back against the Buffalo Sabres,
those sons of bitches,
those fucking people start singing.
It's like gladiator and all of a sudden though does,
if they start skating faster and then you just know they're going to score that
goal to fucking tie it up every goddamn time.
It's like watching Derek Jeter didn't guy on tying runs on second,
you know he's going to slap it a right.
He's going to go the other way with it.
He's going to hit a double,
you know he's actually gonna do okay for all you fucking American League
pitchers.
He's going to look for fast ball.
The first pitch.
That's what he does.
He tries to pull it every fucking time in that situation.
That's what he looks for.
Okay?
But then if you give it to him out over the plate,
he'll take what he gives you and then he slaps it to right field.
All right,
so why don't you throw a high fucking inside fast ball that the bottom drops out
of and at least get strike one on the fuck.
Can you please do that?
Okay.
Sorry.
Let's get a little upset there.
I actually,
you know,
next time I go,
when I'm in New York,
if you're a Yankee fan and he'd come out to my Carolyn's show,
uh,
if you want to see my impression of Derek Jeter at taking a strike right down
the center of the plate,
if you want me to do that impression,
um,
just yell out during the show.
I'm actually encouraging people to heckle me.
What am I doing or whatever.
After the show,
I'll give you my impression of Derek Jeter at bat standing there that does not
move off the shoulder and it's a strike right down the center of the plate.
Without a fucking doubt,
it is a strike.
A goddamn moron could call it a strike.
I will do my impression of his body language taking strike right down the plate.
How many different times you're going to explain it.
All right,
I'm done.
Have a great [inaudible]
take any,
so
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].